July 2019.
Europe is in the grip of a brutal drought.
In the summer, parts of Europe recorded the
hottest heatwave they've experienced in
modern history. In Spain, temperatures climb
to 110°F.
Consequence of this, a lot of bodies of water
began dropping at a rapid rate.
Getting lower than they ever have.
As waters recede and the Extremadura region
of the country.
A ghost from the past is captured by
satellite cameras.
Suddenly, seemingly out of nowhere, this ring
appears on the shoreline.
An almost perfect circle.
The ring shaped mound is around 120ft wide.
It would have taken a significant amount of
effort to build something like this, so it
must have some important significance.
The waters here form part of a reservoir
system.
David Krueger looks at its history for
clues.
This was formed as a result of a dam project
by the infamous General Francisco Franco.
Fascist dictator Franco ruled Spain from
1939 to 1975.
He's kind of Spain's answer to Adolf Hitler.
He's a really brutal leader who ruled with
an iron fist for decades over Spain.
Franco's reign is characterized by violent
oppression of the Spanish people.
I wonder if this formation is something that
General Franco actually wanted to cover up by
flooding the area.
Franco's attempt to seize power causes the
Spanish Civil War of 1936 to 1939 with
support from Hitler and Mussolini.
His nationalist rebels defeat the
Republicans in a conflict that claims around
200,000 lives.
The Spanish Civil War is particularly brutal
because now you're incorporating modern
bombers and tanks into combat, killing
thousands of soldiers.
But also killing thousands of civilians.
Following his victory, Franco embarks on a
campaign of violence and terror on those who
oppose his fascist ideals.
Anybody's enemy of the state, you name it.
Liberals, communists, Christians.
Well, they're all targeted.
They call it the white terror.
Franco's death squads.
Butcher Another 200,000 people.
What happens in Spain is kind of medieval in
its brutality.
You hear stories of death squads carrying
out mass public executions in bull rings and
grizzly tales of supporters supposedly
dancing in the victims blood.
It's utterly barbaric.
Around 140,000 of Franco's victims have never
been found.
Buried in secret mass graves around the
country.
People who were killed and ended up in these
mass graves are known today as Spain's
disappeared. Is it possible that what we see
here is an example of a mass grave site that
Franco covered up underneath the waters?
Yet for Clint Giannoulas further aerial
images of the structure suggest it has a much
older origin.
I believe it predates any industrial
technologies.
You've got these stones that have been
carved and in placed vertically in a
formation that looks like Neolithic sites we
see across the UK and Europe.
The Neolithic, also called the New Stone Age,
begins around 12,000 years ago.
It sees mankind evolving from being hunter
gatherers to farming the land and forming
larger tribes.
And at sites around Europe, mysterious
clusters of standing stones begin to appear.
It's an era in which everything in the world
is changing dramatically, and people suddenly
have the ability to build large things on a
big scale.
The exact purpose of these ancient edifices
is a mystery.
Yet. Giannoulas thinks one section of the
Spanish structure could offer a clue.
The interesting aspect for me is the
entryway.
This is a classic shape that we see in sites
made of stone from the Neolithic and the
early Bronze Age.
Giannoulas calculates that the entryway is
precisely aligned to the rising sun during
the summer solstice.
What that means is on the summer solstice,
the first light of day would have come
through there and lit up the entire inside.
And that makes it possible.
Ritualistic or ceremonial site.
Archaeologists think that the structure once
had a roof creating a prehistoric edifice
called a dolmen.
Dolmens are ritual structures that are
related to death.
We have to remember that with the earth on
top of it, this would have been a very dark
entryway into the underworld.
Into a sacred space for communing with the
ancestors.
Archaeological records offer grim clues as to
how the ancient peoples at this site communed
with their ancestors.
When your relative dies, you might engage in
cannibalism.
This is the idea that you are eating a piece
of your ancestor, that you are literally
taking a piece of them and incorporating it
into your body.
Tests reveal that this ritual death chamber
dates back around 5000 years ago when pagans
worshipped at Stonehenge and pharaohs were
being interred in the Great Pyramids.
But before archaeologists can investigate
further, the waters rise and its ancient
secrets are reclaimed once more.
How lucky are we to get this brief glimpse
from space of this civilization that lived so
many years ago?
Who knows when we'll get to see it again?